de la chambre de pauline viardot il ne
reste plus rien des salons où était
donné concert et bal il ne reste que
quelques peintures la villa est
aujourd'hui en péril laissé à l'abandon
en 2000 je les retrouver pour la
première fois et donc cette maison qui
qui représente tellement pour un
musicien et donc je suis rentré dans ses
salons les j'ai eu mal au coeur j'ai
pleuré pour tout vous dire comment était
ce possible
abandonner un haut lieu de la musique le
domaine est acheté en 1874 par la
cantatrice son mari et le romancier ivan
tourguéniev un lieu de foisonnement
intellectuel dans ses salons et c'est ça
qui est absolument magnifique
nous avons eu tous les grands esprits du
19e siècle de l'oural à l'atlantique
il y avait des russes s'il y avait des
néerlandais il y avait des belles filles
y avait des italiens des anglais a
probablement écrit certains passages du
david copperfield ici qui ont fait de
cette maison un haut lieu de dialogue un
haut lieu d'une conscience européenne
qui se dessinait déjà à cette époque là
des travaux dont le montant s'élève à
près de 3 millions d'euros le site a été
retenu par le loto du patrimoine dont le
premier tirage se fera le 14 septembre
prochain
non seulement c'est la reconnaissance de
ce que cette villa représente 3 millions
d'euros c'est une énorme somme notamment
pour une ville comme bougival qui est
une petite ville de 8000 900 habitants
et donc il est absolument essentiel que
l'état que les institutionnels
s'emparent de ce sujet et permettent la
rénovation de la villa une fois rénové
la villa intégrera un projet touristique
et artistique un grand centre de musique
et que la maison bizet composa son opéra
le plus célèbre carmen